sérieux c'est le tient notre invité
principal ce soir c'est alain chabat
[Applaudissements]
ça va mon soir bonsoir thierry vous êtes
ici ce soir pour annoncer que vous avez
décidé d'apporter votre soutien à
nicolas sarkozy tout à fait elle le
prend bien
moi je suis prêt pour la vanne
[Musique]
oh
chalus alain comont chabat cheveux bien
voilà une du magazine jq j'imagine non
oui oui voilà comment devenir cool drôle
et stylé cool et drôle vous l'avez
toujours été hostile et jamais vous êtes
devenu stylet à partir de 5 millions
d'entrées par film
gt ça c'est un des problèmes de
dominique de farouches par exemple way
qui me dit tu peux pas mettre un
pantalon de jogging avec des chaussures
cirées ça se fait pas oui je faisais
c'est ce qui dit damien sur facebook
allah est toujours mal habillé il ya que
le talent qui compte chez jimmy ou pas
les fringues je suis d'ailleurs et c'est
vrai il ya un j'aime
assez bien déjà c'est vous c'est moi
alors alain drucker baffie d'avant nikos
avant denisot ferrari pujadas hublé et
ardisson où tu devrais donc si vous
n'auriez pas un truc à nous vendre par
hasard non du tout sexe est en train de
battre le record du monde de promo ont
quand même pas du tout car vous avez
fait 57 villes ah oui mais c'est pas de
la promo ça sert la rencontre avec le
public ça d'accord
alors le film a coûté cher c'est pour ça
le film peu importe le prix du film mais
c'est essentiel c'est le spectacle
l'argent est sur l'écran on fait comment
pour répondre aux questions qu'on pose
pour la 50e fois alors que la réponse
est dans le dossier de presse
comment on fait si je te fais un bisou
aux bisous % sur des traces
lorsqu'il va être terrible en fait c'est
que dans les interviews comme ça les
gens attendent que vous soyez drôle tout
le temps alors moi je vous met à l'aise
alain ce soir pas besoin d'être drôle
provoqué by d'un coup il ya eu combien
de questions un peu oiseaux sur la
taille de la queue du marsupilami alors
0 ah ben je suis le premier alors ouais
ouais
alors passons la promo proprement dit
donc après dix ans de recherches sur un
chat bas a enfin trouvé un acteur avec
une queue de 9 mètres de long
et il a porté à l'écran le marsupilami
ouais hein c'est un des personnages de
fred tefana ouais alors le marsupilami
donc film écrit produit réalisé et
interprété par alain chabat alors c'est
comme sacha guitry vous faites tout et
je fais le pop corn aussi à lamballe
alors avec jamel debbouze fred testot
lambert wilson géraldine nakache patrick
timsit aïssa maïga oui liya kebede
jacques weber alors cette histoire de
dan geraldo vous grand reporter qui part
en palombie pour un scoop mais qui avec
l'aide de pabbi tôt joué par djamel un
guide local va découvrir un scoop
beaucoup plus énorme le marsupilami
existe vraiment oui ils existent
vraiment alors ouais on a tourné avec un
vrai ça se voit un vrai martiaux
alors c'est quoi la pyramide date du
tournage c'est à la fois la meilleure
j'ai envie de dire c'est la fois où on a
eu du veau à la cantine ouais
d'accord
c'est pas dur de tourner avec fred
testot parce qu'il paraît qui fait le
con sans arrêt c'est vrai fred c'est
extraordinaire il se réveille avec une
connerie et le dernier truc qui te dit
en partant c'est une connerie quand tu
peux ne peut avoir aucune information
sortant de sa bouche et oui c'est super
non mais c'est extraordinaire à ce point
là le pire moment c'était quoi j'ai pas
eu vraiment de pire moment enfin j'ai eu
de bol ouais on avait peur qu'ils aient
des blessés on était quand même dans la
jungle il est très chaude résume id
vous pouvez le voir il y avait des il y
avait des mille pattes il y avait des
vipères il ya des dessins jeux qui nous
jeter leur caca sur nous d'ailleurs et
on était alors sur leur territoire donc
il pouvait y avoir plein d'accidents et
on a vraiment eu on a fait beaucoup de
rigolade car beaucoup de crétins sur le
tournage et ça je dois dire
alors
[Applaudissements]
en fait c'est une idée qui vient de loin
vous aviez parlé du mas reçue à claude
berri avant astérix et vous avez dit ça
va coûter trop cher mais vaut mieux
faire et eric gellé droit en plus il
vous dit le succès d'astérix m'a permis
de réaliser ce rêve non mais le
j'ai dit ça
non moi j'aime les gens disent qu'ils
ont pas dit ça quand c'est un truc
incroyable ouais non non j'ai su c'est
un chien ça je les dis
non vous avez écrit le scénario à partir
de 25 albums du marsupilami de franquin
non
non non non non c'est un c'est une
histoire originale cinq ans de travail
sur le scénario
oui oui
j'étais au moins un pas dire non à tout
mais j'avais dix ans que j'entends
parler de ça alors non non un
quinze semaines de tournage sur trois
continents ça c'est vrai oui tous les
extérieurs tout les jungles et les
villages de palombes y sont tournés au
mexique on a tourné dès des choses en
belgique et en france et puis on a
tourné aussi des plans larges magnifique
de jungle à à bornéo en malaisie alors
le budget 40 millions d'euros je crois
pas mais on va dire oui
mais c'est moins il faut faire comme un
d'entrée je crois qu'il faut faire au
moins mille 1000 ou 2000 ou 2000 entrées
ah oui quand même le producteur je me
connais tu me fais alors je vais dire
aux gens pourquoi aller le voir d'accord
il faut aller le voir parce que c'est
une comédie ouais c'est un film familial
oui c'est un buddy movie c'est vrai
c'est un film d'aventurés exact c'est un
film pas du type dénonçant le trucage
des médias aussi c'est un film
écologique sur la survie d'une espèce
rare
et c'est une comédie musicale rendant
hommage à céline dion entre autres
j'adore c'est combien de raison que ça
fait trois quatre cinq six sept raisons
quand même fortement oui c'est l'art des
films il ya cette raison
[Rires]
c'est presque seul
alors le marsupilami c'est le plus gros
film français de l'année d'accord ouais
ok quel chemin parcouru depuis massy est
rien c'est vrai
non mais c'est vrai je pensais c'est
vrai mais j'aime bien le plus gros film
de l'année et massy dans la même phrase
je trouve ça super le petit rapatriés
d'algérie oui le crétin rebelles et
boutonneux comme vous dites en parlant
de vous à cette époque qui lisait des bd
pour échapper à l'ennui et pour le kiff
surtout oui oui vous disiez à l'époque
quand est-ce que je vais sortir de là
pour faire enfin ce que j'ai vraiment
envie de faire c'est vrai mais je le
disais avec une fois moins graves ah oui
j'avais j'avais 14 ans est-ce que je
vais pour vincent
alors votre maire disait ses frères
feront médecine lille sera dentiste où
il finira kiné au pire
pas gentil pour les kinés oui mais vous
vous y êtes vous le dise non à l'époque
moi je voulais être successeur de walt
disney par règlement c'est pour vous
dire de la mégalomanie du mec je
rappelle à nos amis téléspectateurs que
pendant toute l'émission alain chabat
est susceptible d'être appelé sur son
portable par le ceinturait je crois
qu'on on peut le dire non
oui ça commence là basterds la part des
gens qui se réveille très tôt qu'ils se
réveillent maxence et revoilà pas du
tout non maintenant je sortais un film
avec eddie murphy non ah oui exact un
film qui s'appelle en anglais mille mots
c'est une idée de deux auteurs français
qu'on a développée dans ma boîte de prod
que je voulais faire en france et puis
et puis un moment voilà j'ai le truc
c'est pas fait j'ai vendu l'idée aux
états unis à paramount et dreamworks et
puis le scénar à un moment s'est mis en
route quand eddie murphy s'est intéressé
à l'idée et voilà surtout j'ai croisé
eddie murphy donc mais j'étais content
j'étais au top de ma vie c'est le 16 mai
oui vous êtes deux films de chabat allez
voir quand même hein
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus